[Music]
over the last two years we've been
looking at a bunch of different open
houses but now we have a baby on the way
so it's serious we partnered with
realtor.com to give you guys a
three-part series that's all about our
process of trying to find a house we saw
a bunch of different houses last week
and we picked the spanish-style
fixer-upper oh my gosh I'm so excited we
wrote a letter saying we're expecting up
to a B soon and that we love the
neighborhood but the question is Ariel
yes did we get the house let's talk
about how we're gonna make this house
our home and you know what I want I want
this to be like a big great room it's
got a sort of like see like yeah we've
got the new my home section of
realtor.com up if all this remodeling
we're doing we're gonna want to track
the value of our home but first let's
look at some design inspiration I like
the look of this space the fireplace is
like a really central piece yeah so
maybe we could take the brick and like
paint it white I think really lovely
we know the door needs fixing yes
what are we gonna do about that I
couldn't like this this darker color
here yeah I think we need the really
sort of regal looking Hardware cold
accents on a blue door that would look
really nice that was look really nice we
can get a big old knocker
like Julie for knocking yeah it's nice
this is probably one of the weirdest
spots yeah it's passed its way from the
hallway to the master which is really
strange
yeah either need to close this door or
put it on hallway and as much as I love
it
we might need to get rid of our paneling
it's like an eighties Ben this is your
house being you have a house no no it's
miss ball so here is our lovely little
two steps down beautiful carpet this
carpet is going bye-bye - spiders as far
as master bathrooms go yeah Oh Stevie
it's very exciting project we're
planning on expanding the exterior walls
of the master bedroom all of that dirt
spot outside it's going to be bathroom
this is the kitchen here and it needs a
lot of work these cabinets get him out
of there it looks nasty gonna take out
all this all that all this but it's
gonna turn into an entire open kitchen
concept I like this cut like the marble
with the gold sauces yeah that's a
classy little rascal the actual kitchen
part of it is gonna go over here and
then like three steps away we're gonna
have an island it's like boom boom boom
I'm cooking right serving
Island eat-in Island on it what have we
done in there around what we've done we
own this house now I like it too
it's so much worse he has told me bean I
need you to take a deep breath you're
right you're right no you're right okay
I'm excited to tear yourself down me too
it's demo time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like how many decades worth of
poops have been in here you got it here
we go we have this right a lot yeah but
maybe our first DIY project could be
that sticky front door yes
[Music]
right swing
[Music]
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that you just spread rat
turds all over the floor yeah what now
we're going to finish the door with this
beautiful rich blue paint I'm getting
some fumes area yeah maybe I should just
paint it and you can like give me
feedback from Ned that's that's like
really sick but you actually you're not
doing it really no you're like actually
not doing it
look at mine just like that you can see
the line I'm sorry maybe I need a
respirator it doesn't fit I don't think
it fits see you got it way too thick
right here huh we got a toothpick okay
seriously seriously dizzy right now
every single time
[Music]
yeah so look at this area where we gonna
put that knocker
I like that knocker it's like right Dan
is that too small no nope too low
yep too hot nope how do we tell how high
is too high perfect
all right let's check it out oh nice
it's so much better than it was well
mrs. Palmer are you ready to check out
our new house yep well it's a start
high feeling right now look good I'm
happy at you that was a tiring day that
was a long day there's so many things
happening in our life right now having a
baby would be crazy enough but to think
about how our lives will change having a
baby and had a new house a new house it
feels really special that this place is
ours and ours alone
and we can do whatever we want right
also when I think about how far we've
come on this journey honey we've been
looking for houses for like two years
well a couple of weeks ago we were
seeing a mansion that we totally
couldn't afford but love but love then
we were able to compromise on our needs
for certain wants when we put the new
door on our hinges yeah it was like for
just a moment I was like this is what
it's like haha
I felt that wait a minute we've knocked
through the wall cracking through some
of these walls it was pretty fun this
house may not be perfect for everyone
IDenticard oh man first
yeah I like that it better be because
this baby's coming whether we like it or
not that was my boob that was no I'm are
you thinking oh really good
[Music]
well that's a safe yeah and I think this
whole thing is unsafe